so I'm just going to jump right in oh
wow I did not expect this season to kick
off with Susanna's death already having
happened uh Rachel when did you find out
about that news and were you worried for
a minute like did I just lose my job
well I think I found out
when did we get the scripts
I can't remember when we got oh yeah
yeah
not it was kind of close to when we
started shooting
um I had read the books so I knew I
wasn't long for the world
oh yeah so it after Susanna's death we
see Julia come back into the world uh
into the story and I like you know the
Dynamics that she had with all these
different characters what do you think
for you was the defining aspect of
Julia's life that helped you sort of
grab a hold of this character and how do
you think that life changes after she
sort of reconciles with her family yeah
I mean I think that she doesn't wish I
think that on some level Julia really
wishes that she did have the view of the
world that Susanna had and that that was
something that she could that she could
be more joyful
um but that but that Julia didn't have
that experience you know they had the
same father but they had different
mothers and and um
and my experience of being in that house
was that I really wasn't welcome there
whereas you know for her it was always
just the most welcoming place in the
world and it was it was as if I had
changed but really I didn't I didn't
change just the circumstances changed
you know he he broke up with my my
mother and you know and so it was never
it was never a home for me it was always
just a house and for her it was nothing
but a home yeah definitely and Jackie I
think out of everyone Laurel is probably
by Susanna's side the most on those like
final days uh but she also seems to be
the person coping the best out of
everyone how do you think she holds it
together or is it more about the fact
that she recognizes she has to be the
most responsible one yeah I I don't know
if she's actually coping the best but it
probably appears that way from the
outside I think she realizes that they
are each other's closest person and she
is the one that's going to help take
care of her and so she needs to remain
strong also take care of her kids also
you know be a single mother
um so I think for most of the Season
she's just containing it until she kind
of has to let it out yeah and I think
there's a really interesting dynamic
between these three women because in a
way I feel like Susanna's sort of after
her sister left there's this replacement
with um with Laurel and there's like
some somewhat of attention there do you
guys feel that like there was ever a
universe where perhaps Susanna survived
and she you know overcame
um her illness and the three of them
became friends and their kids could have
grown up together or is there too much
baggage there do you think it never
would have become as uh as congruent as
it it'd be nice to think that that could
happen sometimes I feel it takes
tragedies to bring those things together
the people together in that way and that
tragedy was Susanna's death so I don't
know if there would have been an event
that would have brought them together
but I think of Skye and the kids all
really missing out on that right yeah we
kind of robbed them of that experience
against the cousins together yeah so
hopefully there would have been
something that brought them together
yeah because I think that yeah I think
that connection with the kids is good
yeah yeah
um obviously this is a show with a large
cast and everyone sort of is in their
own Corners a little bit is there a
character that you guys wish that your
characters had more screen time with or
somebody you have more of a connection
developing with and um Rachel I'll start
with you I mean my scenes were quite
contained this season so but I would
have liked to have had more scenes this
season with both of you that would have
been fun same yes yeah same I also it
would have been nice to see the girls
together you know yeah
oh yeah right exactly yeah yeah and I'm
I'm asking this question to everybody
um who do you guys think for you guys
personally who do you guys think um
belly should end up with is it Conrad or
is it um Jeremiah I'm gonna say Conrad
just to mix it up
she doesn't need to choose you should
have many lovers it could be someone
entirely different
that's a that's a different answer that
I was getting from some of the other
cast members but what were they saying
yeah what were they saying well um I
think rain and um David
oh no Elsie and David both said Conrad
and Rain said Jeremiah which I agree
with because I think Conrad was a little
bit
there was there was too much this season
he was a little bit too wishy-washy I
think I'm too old for that type of
energy in my life so I don't think I
love that
um but yeah is there an aspect of your
guys's character that you want to
explore more
um just you know maybe a part that might
not even be filmed but it's something
that you want to like dig into
yeah I want to do a road trip see I
think it'd be fun to be a fun World trip
yeah it would be fun
all three yeah yeah
I think it would be kind of a chaotic
road trip I mean that's that's yeah
dramatic moment that you guys can Bond
over is being forced into space together
yeah okay well I really want to thank
you guys for speaking with me
um I really enjoyed this season I love
the new edition and I love sort of
seeing this this show grow every season
and I can't wait to see what you guys
come up with next so thank you for
speaking with me thank you so much thank
you